that's right so I decided to give a very
high level entertaining sort of overview
talk some of you may have already seen
part of it so let's let's get right into
it so usually when we look at complexity
or when we have looked at complexity in
counting then we have wondered whether
it's in p or not in P so is it in where
FP of not NP so in exact counting sort
of the dichotomy is between P versus
sharply hard and an approximate counting
maybe we have a kind of trichotomy
situation where it's either either it
has an approximation scheme or it's
based complete or it's as hard to
approximate a set but really it comes
down to can it be approximated in
polynomial time or not under reasonable
complexity assumptions such as RP is
equal to NP or not it equal to so I
would argue that this is this is all
great but maybe even once we have
classified our problems according to
this sort of setting we want to know
even more so the motivation for
fine-grained complexity and there was a
program about this last semester here at
simons which i attended and this here is
kind of my the advertisement sort of
talk for this for this area so the
motivation is as follows so even if you
have a problem that's Sharpie hard then
you could still want to solve it and
there are different sort of situations
that he could be in right so it could be
that the best running time is 2 to the N
or even 200 to the M or it's one point
or 12 the end which is maybe already
very efficient for the instances that
you look at or or you can could have
some parameter in your input that's very
small and
algorithm and some time enter decay or
even two to the K times them so there is
a very different range of possibilities
here and for problems in P we have a
similar sort of story well how how much
in p is it like it has been argued or it
has been said that every problem in p is
actually is audible in like cubic time
or linear time every natural problem
that is but there are actually example
the problems where we don't know linear
time algorithm for quadratic time
algorithm and we want to multiple
problems NP distinguish between the run
these different situations don't even
know the Charpy problems are not in the
sec or not on that second log yeah so
even assuming that p is not equal to
choppy yeah of course this is all
conditional what I'm saying and
hypothetical okay so fine grained
complexity gives you a toolbox it will
be a conditional toolbox we can never
prove things anytime soon so fine
growing complexity is a toolbox for
pinning down the exact running times
further okay so what so what kinds of
tools we have well in the orthogonal in
the polynomial time world we have
various problems for which we know
algorithms that we think may be the best
algorithms possible for example the
orthogonal vectors problem it's the
problem very giving a bunch of you're
given a bunch of vectors and you want to
find two of them that are orthogonal the
best known algorithms it's believed that
they are actually optimal and the all
pair shortest path problem so the best
no argument there is a cubic time and
it's believed that it's not
better than cubic time and similar for
3some it's a quadratic time there is a
quadratic time algorithm and it's
believed or it's at least reasonable
assumption that we can use to build up
some some complexity is that n cube is
actually the n square is actually the
best possible for for this sort of thing
but in the counting world we don't
really we don't have I don't have
anything that specifically relates to
counting in the polynomial time world
therefore what I will focus on the other
side and there we have parameter wise
complexity which will which rather we'll
talk about later this week and we have
the sort of the exponential time setting
which is the focus of this talk so let's
just as a quick starter let's look at
how we can actually be faster than
exhaustive search so for example for
three CNF SAT there is Sterling's
algorithm which is based on a markov
chain method it's very simple you
randomly start from a random you start
from a random assignment for the
variables there are n variables and then
if there is a clause it's not satisfied
by the assignment if there is no clothes
that's not satisfied by the assignment
you found your satisfying assignment
we're done if there is a clause that's
not satisfied well then we we pick a
random little rule in that class and we
flip it doing so will now satisfy the
clause
and hopefully it brings us closer to a
satisfying assignment and then there was
a restart process which which we select
there in the in the if this while loop
takes too long we just restart this
whole process and sample from a
completely new assignment start from
completely new sound so that the
analysis goes something like this so
let's assume we have some satisfying
assignment somewhere and it's plot the
Hamming distance of the assignments that
we look at what a random assignment will
have half of the variables set correctly
and half of them not correctly in
expectation with some probability even
more than half of them will be set
correctly and that's actually also
exploited in the the analysis and then
when you flip a value well with
probability one third you know that the
satisfying assignment has the completely
doesn't have doesn't agree with the non
satisfying assignment on this clause so
you so you know that you have to flip at
least one of these variables to get
closer to the satisfying assignment and
that probability one third you get
closer the probability at most two third
you get further away from this ok so
this sort of is a very simple Markov
chain on a on a path because you're just
looking at the distance here either the
distance get smaller or bigger and if
you analyze this with the with the
restart and the fact that actually with
some probability more than half of the
variables are set correctly initially
already you can get the running time of
four thirds to the M that's the expected
running time of this of is a gratin and
it it's a decision algorithm ok so you
can't you can't really count this way
the worst case for this worse than the
exhaustive search worst case
pardon me so that's the expected running
time but suppose you know it's it's a
badly it's a very clutter of graph or
something you know can-can this
algorithm do worse than the exhaustive
search so it depends on how you define
randomized algorithm so you can just
repeat it a constant number of times for
example and if it never if it never
finds a satisfying assignment you're
just a bored and then you claim that
there is no satisfying assignment but
maybe you make an error right it's kind
of a one sided arrow that you can make
here or you can just let it run forever
and in expectation this would be the
running time these are two equivalent
sort of views okay but this does not
count so a different methods that can
count is is a branching algorithm so
here we have a formula with three CNF
formula and let's say it has some class
ABC and let's say we branch from the
variables on these literals in order so
either a is one or a zero if a is one
that the clause is satisfied and we
don't sort of look at it anymore in the
analysis then B can be one with 0 nce
can be 1 or 0 except that it can't be
that all three literals are 0 so there
was one case that we can just exclude we
don't have to branch from this one so in
total for every class sort of we only
need to look at seven out of the eight
possible assignments and that gives an
improvement over exhaustive search so
now we only need seven to the end third
time okay and this this analysis is
extremely crude yes so you can do it you
can do it much better and improve this
constant
and in fact you can improve the rule the
bits you but which you choose which
variable to pan for next more cleverly
like you would probably want to branch
on high degree variables so variables
that occur very often first and if you
do this then you get an exact algorithm
that has 1 point 6 4 to the n running
time and that's the currently best known
it has been proven a long time ago yes
ok and then why would we only look at
exact count like we could also be
interested in approximate or be are
interested in approximate counting and
mark thoroughly actually proved an hour
gave an algorithm an approximation
algorithm that has a faster sort of
exponential running time for
satisfiability and this is the only
approximation algorithm for sat that has
ever been sort of device em in this in
this fourth reset sort of industry and
reality yeah and now given that we can
do faster than 2 to the N one question
is how would it be a constant food again
were the best algorithm running time
constant to the end and the exponential
time hypothesis says that yes so there
is a constant delta such that counting
CNF SAT for three senior formulas cannot
be done on time 1 plus delta 2 dear
yeah so if delta happens to be 0.6 for
two or three then we already have found
the best soccer with what this seems
right I mean we have no reason to think
that this is the stupid you find an
answer and so one important alema and is
in this context to make this a robust
sort of hypothesis and theory is the
specification limit which says that we
can actually assume that the number of
clauses in the 3sat formula is linear
when you consider Delta to be a constant
so the hard cases where the formula is
sparse in this sense let me say this a
bit more precisely so the input is a
case in a formula with n variables and M
clauses and also you get an epsilon as
an input parameter which will feed into
the running time and the sparsity that
you want to achieve the output is now a
bunch of k sienna formulas so that
actually to satisfy the set of
satisfying assignments of the input
formula is can be written as the
disjoint union of the satisfying
assignments of the output formulas
and since it's a disjoint Union this
reduction can also be used in the
counting setting it's a parsimonious
thing that's going on here and moreover
every output formula has a loop has K
over epsilon to the K density and there
are only very few output formulas okay
so the the running time of this
algorithm is polynomial in its output
actually it's T times the polynomial and
T is sub exponential so t is 2 to the
epsilon iam so as epsilon if epsilon is
very small this will allow us to say
something about the precise exponential
running times for linear sort of
instances or province problems on sparse
instances
okay let's move on so Jen in general C&S
so not only three CNF SAT for general
synapse we can also get some savings
over exhaustive search for example Chan
and William status here in a
deterministic algorithm so they compute
a number of satisfying assignments in
time two to the N times 1 minus from
savings the savings they get depend on
the on the structure of the formula so
if it's a case in if the savings is
proportional to 1 over K and if F is
sparse so if it has C times and clauses
but k may be large in this case then the
savings is 1 over log see okay so in any
case as K goes to infinity we don't
become better than put force here we
have so we don't have an algorithm that
is better than 2 to the N for all K or
for general conf that we don't have that
and therefore we have the strong
exponential time hypothesis which you
may or may not believe which is that
actually this is this this is true in
general so no algorithm can have savings
more than Delta that for all K so for
all that for all Delta there is a large
K such that case in episode cannot be
solved or countered with savings better
than Delta
so this means that CNF sides cannot be
done in 1.99 to the M so okay so once we
have this hypothesis which problems
which problems are equivalent to it I
mean in in the classical polynomial time
world we have sats and then we have
audio NP complete problems or sharpy
complete problems but I'll just end of
the strong eth the old reductions they
may or may not work and in fact we know
very few problems that are equivalent to
see an episode under these strong eth
preserving reductions in the decision
world we have problems such as hitting
set so finding a hitting set of size K
that's a vertex cover in a hyper graph
or not all equal side these problems
that are very close to CNF set they
still remain equivalent so one has a
faster than 22 DNR goutham if the other
has if and only if the other one has but
these reductions are already quite
surprisingly non-trivial you cannot use
the standard NP hardness direction and
then interestingly it's open whether set
covers of size t having a faster
algorithm for this weather that
equivalent to strong eth
okay so what did we learn from counting
come taxi well if we don't if we can't
continue on the decision word so if you
can't get the dichotomy for the decision
problem which sort of arises quite a bit
for example the feed Avari conjecture
the is an instance of this where we
don't know whether the dichotomy holes
or whether certain happiness reductions
exists we look at the counting version
in here let's say we could look at
counting modulo 2 and in counting modulo
2 we have this equivalence as well and
of course we can always reduce from the
decision version to the counting we're
using an isolation level so the original
involvement was evaluated later number
does not work here because you have to
do it more efficiently it has to be it
has to be encoded into a case enf and
you cannot encode arbitrary linear
equations into a case in app so you need
to do it with sparse linear equations
and so the point is that in the counting
world we do get in the confluence to to
set covers so counting hitting sets of a
certain size is actually it turns out to
be a criminal to counting all hitting
sets and this surprisingly modulo 2 is
equal to the problem of counting all set
covers and it's equal to the problem of
countering bipartite independent sets
modulo 2
this is hard and from there there is a
reduction to set covers modulo 2 of size
tea set covers of size t although the
back reduction is not known and we also
have a decision to parity reduction from
set cover down here just to complete
this picture so that we understand the
counting word a little bit better than
the decision road which is yeah so
that's a good thing let's move on yeah
I'm just talking about to several
results in this area as soon as I said
just an overview let's look at perfect
matchings so we have the matrix that
corresponds to this bipartite graph
these are some perfect matchings that
the number of perfect matchings is equal
to the permanent of the of the matrix
and that's equal to the sum of all
permutations and then can you take this
this product so so how fast can you
compute the permanent well one algorithm
is as follows you just use this formula
and that will take time d factorial
roughly ready it was a dimension of the
matrix but the factorial is not so it's
not the best you can do you can actually
do it faster using inclusion exclusion
so you write the set of limitations as
the set of all functions so let's say
instead of the permutations we look at
all functions this some you can express
using some polynomial size i do park
circuit so this is just a product of
polynomially many things of the somewhat
polynomially many things
but now of course we / counted we
counted functions that are not
surjective say so we remove them so we
remove all functions that don't hit a
certain element but now we undercounted
because there are functions that don't
hit two elements and so on so it's just
include an exclusion which yields Rises
formula yes but this is long ago so
this gives us a running time of 2 to the
D or F lee yeah so we went down from the
factorial 2 2 to the D which is arguably
better but we don't know we don't really
know whether this is optimal so let's
look at lower bounds the only thing
that's known at this point it is under
ETH under number eth that the permanent
cannot be completed in sub exponential
time not in 22 the little of G let me
mention another upper bound so if a has
if a is sparse so this is also analogous
to the satisfiability case if a is
sparse then you can compute it better
than to to do to to the d
and in light of this and the fact that
we have a fifty-year-old algorithm that
has not been improved you may we could
look at the hypothesis that the
permanent can actually not be computed
faster than 2 to the D so it would be
looked something like this the permanent
is not in time to minus Delta to the D
from and you can make it even gradual
like in the limit if you look at sparse
matrices yeah since I'm running out of
time let me quickly go over this so you
can also count perfect matchings and
general graphs as fast as you can
compute Rises formula and I guess this
would also be an instance of a problem
where that is hard under the permanent
exponential time of offices so you
cannot do this faster unless you can do
the permanent pastor and here i'm just
showing that the chromatic polynomial is
the polynomial and i was just saying ok
so did this algorithm the deletion
contraction algorithm for the chromatic
polynomial takes 2 to the M time you can
also do an invert exponential time but
probably not better than that and then
the strong ugh we don't know then we
have the top polynomial which I don't
sort of need to define this crowd it's
just this polynomial that takes edge
exponential time you can do it in vertex
exponential time it's the same story and
you can probably not do it better than
that let me give the obligatory picture
for the top plane and I'm only showing
this in order to highlight the open
problem
okay so we have to cycle to me some
points of the tab polynomial can be
computed in polynomial time most of the
points are hard on the eth under Sharpie
th but this line the yellow line is open
under Sharpie th and it's a very if I
made no mistake it's a very simple
problem it's the forest counting problem
so you sum of all forests seen a subset
of the edges and the weight of the
forest is two to the number of edges in
the force okay so this problem is
sharply hard but we don't know whether
it's hard under ETH or number eh here I
wanted to say I'm running out of time so
I wanted to say something about Locke
interpolation which how to introduce to
prove the previous result so the basic
idea is that you instead of looking at
univariate interpolation if you look at
multivariate interpolation and you make
sure that every variable that you use in
the india tribulation has a constant
degree and then this allows you to only
use a constant number of different
gadgets in the reductions you don't need
you don't need a large number of
different reduction cathode
okay and this this technique can be used
to rule out sup exponential time
algorithms one word about approximate
counting so if if we have an NP Oracle
then there is an F press for number set
and in this exponential time board we
have some word of an analogy here if C
and F set can be decided in time c2dm
for some see less than two then actually
you can get some kind of F press or some
kind of approximation which is one plus
some exponentially small number so it's
much better than a constant
approximation in time c plus some very
small number okay so if you can decide
set faster than 2 to the M then you can
also approximate set faster than to do
near this is justice
and then lastly so if the strong eth is
true then see an eps that takes time to
julienne you cannot do it faster number
c and f that also takes time to the gym
even approximating numbers in each side
and QB f sub takes time to do so sort of
these problems are all the same and the
question question would be my question
why would we why would we even look at
counting complexity why wouldn't be it
be enough to study problems under sort
of decision complexity assumptions but
maybe 11 hope is that in practice we
observed that CNF SAT is easier than Q
we have set so it might still be so it
so it might still be possible to say
that there could be a kind of total
theorem also in this exponential time
setting which would be a reduction from
QB episode 2 counting seen episode which
would then say that counting is harder
than decision it least in practice
okay i'm going to just mention this open
problem or leave this open problems here
and thank you for your attention
so do you think what exactly looking
exponential time resolution as computers
become faster exponential time is sort
of feasible track people I mean SAT
solvers are based on on dll style
algorithms which yeah it's this
branching process that i showed in the
beginning that and of course some
heuristic techniques sort of inebriation
they don't do an operation but there are
variants were they do that I guess let's
thank Holger again